[Music]
now it's bricks it's intractable problem
and the biggest stumbling block to
getting a deal but Therese Mays
reportedly amount to give more ground to
the EU over the Irish border issue so
who better to talk to you this week than
Islands Deputy Prime Minister and the
Minister for Foreign Affairs and Trade
Simon Cove me I spoke to him on Friday
and started by asking about his brexit
roadshow around Ireland for many decades
now we have got used to the privilege
really of all operating within the same
customs union the same single mark at
the same European Union so Ireland and
Britain have been like one single market
with free movement of goods people
services capital and so as businesses
grow and expand in Britain they can
expand seamlessly into Ireland and vice
versa and as a result of that we have a
a seventy billion euro trade
relationship east-west between Ireland
and the UK we have 38,000 Irish
companies the trade with Britain every
month most of them every week and a
similar number in the UK the trade with
Ireland so that kind of seamless trading
relationship is of course being called
into question now I mean what you're
saying that it really underlines just
how crucial it is for Island that there
is a deal and so we're in October time's
running out this was supposed to be the
month when the deal was going to be
sorted I'm interested to get your
thoughts on the percentage chances of
getting a deal and when you think it's
likely to happen if it if at all well I
mean the first thing I think we need to
be clear on is is what we mean when we
talk about getting a deal in in
october/november because nobody is
talking about signing off on the future
relationship and all of the detail of
what the trading environment will look
like what we're trying to do now over
the next few weeks is to get agreement
on what's called a withdrawal treaty
which is a legal document that deals
with with some of the clarity so what's
the chances you think is getting now I
think the chances are good because I
think the consequences of not getting
withdrawal treaty agreed are very very
negative indeed for the UK
also for Ireland and indeed for many
countries in in the EU I don't forget
that the withdrawal treaty is already
about 90 percent agreed in terms of text
the issues that haven't been signed are
fun yet relate predominantly to Ireland
and what's needed now is the two
negotiating teams need to lock
themselves in a room for the next ten
days or so
the British government needs to come
forward with the new texts that it's
promised in an effort to solve this
Irish border issue that the British
Prime Minister has committed to solve
and we need the two negotiating teams
hammering out a deal that is politically
saleable in Britain and is politically
acceptable across the EU that's going to
be difficult I expect that it would be a
bumpy ride but I believe that it can be
done and will be done because the
consequences of not doing a deal is
really very negative for everybody I
mean could be done this month I think it
can if the willingness is there to show
some flexibility and generosity on both
sides don't forget that the EU does have
fundamental things that it that it needs
to protect through these negotiations -
because there are 27 countries that are
staying in the European Union while
Britain leaves and those countries are
very demanding of Michele Barney in
terms of his role in protecting the
functioning of the singer Marcus the
integrity of the customs union the
trading environment that all of us have
benefited from and so the British Prime
Minister has a tough job but to her
credit she has made clear commitments to
Ireland and to the EU in relation to
protecting a peace process on the island
of Ireland in relation to ensuring that
we are not going to see as an unintended
consequence of brazzers the re-emergence
of border infrastructure on the island
of Ireland as she has committed to
prevent any barriers to trade of course
between Northern Ireland and the rest of
the United Kingdom and we respect that
but if Britain is determined to leave
the customs union and leave the single
market as well as leave the European
Union well then it's very difficult to
get these things right but I do believe
it's possible to do it I believe we are
going to see some new thinking from the
British government in terms of a new
paper
the sooner we see that the better so
that we can assess it
the reports are that Teresa may as you
say is shifting her position on the
Irish backstop reportedly a lot ready to
allow some regulatory checks in the
Irish Sea and keeping the UK in
effectively a customs union I mean so
far you've been presented a bit as the
bad cop in all this so is this something
that you're willing to compromise on
perhaps to meet her halfway well I mean
first of all I mean this isn't you
thinking because you know the the
British team produced a paper on the 6th
of June which talked about a uk-wide
backstop on customs there was also a
recognition that the regulatory
alignment issues in terms of the rules
of the single market that needed to be
addressed and don't forget that Northern
Ireland already has checks between
Northern Ireland and the UK she has
moved on regulations they have no but
but I think and it's it's important to
say this to reassure people like a lot
of people assume that there are no
regulatory checks between the United
Kingdom and Northern Ireland today there
are around animal safety animal health
plant health and so on on regulations
well I mean well well we don't know that
yet until we see the detail of a paper
so what we have been promised is that a
new paper will be put on the negotiating
table by the British government we look
forward to seeing that we want to be as
constructive as we can be to find a way
forward here I don't forget Ireland has
always advocated and continues to
advocate for the closest possible future
relationship between Britain and Ireland
and Britain in the EU we don't want to
see any unnecessary checks between
Britain and and Ireland but if Britain
is determined to leave the customs union
in single market well then some checks
are unavoidable last week I spoke to
David Davis the former brexit secretary
who said he was very hopeful of getting
a deal as well but he said that the
situation in Ireland was an inconvenient
exaggeration and that things weren't as
difficult to sort out as they've been
painted out effectively is he right well
I mean well I hope he's right that we
can resolve these things in the next two
weeks before the next EU leaders meeting
but I'm afraid it is complex you know
I'm afraid anybody anybody who who
understands the last 20 years in
Northern Ireland since the Good Friday
Agreement
the fragility of politics and community
relations in Northern Ireland the fact
that we haven't had devolved government
in Northern Ireland for nearly 22 months
now it is a very difficult political
environment relationships and the island
of Ireland historically are complex and
so we need to make sure that nothing
happens as an unintended consequence of
Briggs's that damages or undermines
relationships in the island of Ireland
that so many people have worked so hard
to protect and I think Teresa made to
her credit understands that and will
follow through on the commitments that
she's made to Ireland and a quick
thought from you because of course in
the UK there has been some consternation
perhaps about some of the actions or
Donald tusks the president of the EU
Council now he effectively posted an
Instagram picture didn't he where he
poked fun at Teresa May with a with a
picture of her looking at some cakes
talking about cherry picking this was at
a time when she was effectively
humiliated in Salzburg did you look at
that and think he's gone a bit far
that's not very helpful is it well I'm
not sure a Theresa May was humiliated in
Salzburg that's the first thing I mean
clearly there was a political
disagreements there but nobody wants to
humiliate anybody here Theresa May has a
lot of respect across the European Union
she has a lot of respect in Ireland I
can tell you because she has faced down
many people in the British political
system who don't want to prioritize the
issues of Ireland and Northern Ireland
who want to press ahead with a brexit
that would cause a lot of damage to
British Irish relations Theresa May has
faced that down and has refused to
accept that approach and that has gained
her a lot of respect and support in this
country I can tell you because she
understands the the responsibilities
that the British and Irish governments
together have through Briggs's to
protect relationships whether they be
unionists or nationalists or inter
community relationships on this island
we will work with her on that to find a
way through